the conditions were Optimum as the
countdown proceeded Dragon SpaceX
two separate Mission controls one for
Axion and the other for the SpaceX team
five four three two one entrance full
power and liftoff
then the Falcon 9 rocket eased up the
launch platform and the journey began
the crew includes veteran NASA astronaut
Peggy Whitson as commander and three
private customers paying an estimated 55
million dollars each businessman John
schoffner and two Saudi Nationals who
are graduates of Saudi Arabia's first
astronaut program we are really uh
thrilled and excited for our mission and
to represent Saudi Arabia on this
journey I'm really looking forward to
all the experiments we're going to be
conducting on board the International
Space Station biomedical researcher
rayana banawi will be responsible for
many of these experiments and before the
launch she expressed her Pride at
becoming the first Saudi woman in space
I have worked for the past 10 years as a
researcher so research has been my
passion in life I have worked on stem
cells and tissue re-engineering and I'm
very happy and honored to be here today
representing the government of Saudi
Arabia and the sadist commission as the
the first Saudi women astronaut going to
the International Space Station the two
will join a United Arab Emirates
National who's already on the space
station Sultan al-nayadi tweeting out
this view of Saudi Arabia welcoming his
colleagues and celebrating the first
ever time that three Arab astronauts
will be in space together
ax2 is the first commercial space flight
mission to include both private
astronauts and those representing
foreign governments a perfect Fusion of
corporate individual and national
interests
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington